The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN:
So we're here.
So we're in lecture four,
and this is really exciting
because we're going to be
talking about an application.
We sort of spent three lectures
introducing and building up
some of the framework
that the computer solves
to do quantum
mechanics, and now we're
going to actually look
at a real problem.
It's a really cool problem.
And then that'll sort of--
we'll follow up with this.
We might do a little bit more
of this to start on Tuesday,
and then we'll talk
about hydrogen storage is
another problem.
We'll go back after that
to a little more formalism
to get to solids because
these are molecules so far,
and then we'll do
some more problems.
OK, so that's our plan.
What I want to do today is
I want to review a little.
Since I didn't-- so Michelle
came in and gave the lecture,
lecture number three, because
I was in San Francisco.
And so I'd like to review
some of the key points
from that lecture.
So we're going to review
a little bit to start.
And then I want to do some
interactive calculations
together because,
first of all, there's
no better way to
spend time, really,
with a person or
a class or any--
to compute together is
to know one another.
And through these interactive
calculations on the hydrogen
dimer, we will
pose some questions
and answer them
together, make sure
that we're kind of
collectively understanding
some of the key points of
the first three lectures.
Then I'll tell you about why
this is such a cool problem,
what solar thermal
fuels are, and why this
is such a cool energy problem.
And then we'll end with a
discussion and some more
interactive calculations
of the solar thermal fuels
and kind of talking about
why we need quantum mechanics
to tackle this problem.
So that's our plan.
Is anybody else-- yeah,
we're good with that?
We got a thumbs up.
I'm ready to go.
I love it.
You can give me a little private
thumbs up like that any time,
and I love that
kind of feedback.
That's helpful.
And I was actually
thinking that you
were thinking of the Celtics
securing the division
title anyway.
I think you talked about this.
This is sort of
where you started
because we had this kind
of quantum mechanics
that we couldn't solve.
And then we said, well, but
you can solve it analytically
for hydrogen, and we did.
And we said that that explained
the periodic table, amazingly,
if you only had one
electron and one proton.
Unfortunately everything
has a lot more than that,
and what happens
is that when you
put more than one
quantum-mechanical particle--
by which I mean what?
AUDIENCE: More
than one electron.
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN: Electrons.
For us, that's the
quantum-mechanical particle
that we care about.
Of course there are more
quantum-mechanical particles
than that in the world.
Everything is
quantum mechanical,
but those are the
things we really
care about in this class.
And if you put more than
one into the whole thing,
then you've got to think about
how they talk to each other,
and that's the killer.
So you can talk about
how they talk to the ion.
That's this 1 over r term--
how they talk to the
proton I mean, right?
But talking to each other,
that's this many-body problem.
It's called the
many-body problem.
That's really hard, and
analytically it's a nightmare,
and that's where
computation comes in.
Unfortunately, so this
is sort of showing--
this is just all review for the
first little bit of this class.
I want to talk about review.
Those good-old days of
one electron are over.
They were good.
They were fun.
We had a blast for one lecture,
and now we're moving on,
and we're going to multibody,
many-body problems.
And that's the many-body
Schrodinger equation.
And you can see
that the thing goes
from this where you get
those hydrogenic orbitals
and everything's
beautiful to this
where it's just a complete
mathematical nightmare.
And this cannot be
solved analytically.
And so these are sums
over all of the ions,
sums over all the electron-ion
interactions and sums
over all the electron-electron
interactions.
This is the killer right here.
We make some approximations.
That's how we get there
because as I talked about
in the beginning, even if
our computers were seriously
like 10 orders of magnitude
faster than they are today,
we still wouldn't be able
to solve this problem
in a straightforward way.
We cannot solve it
directly and exactly,
so we have to make
approximations.
One of the first
ones we make is--
oh, and that's just
those are the labels.
One of the first ones
we make are-- right,
there's the equation.
That's the
Schrodinger equation--
is this Born-Oppenheimer
approximation.
I think Michelle probably
showed you my tattoo.
Did you see the tattoo?
That was my--
I tried to find a good
image for Born-Oppenheimer,
and that came up first.
And then did she
talk about-- no?
So when I found the image,
I found it on a blog.
And that's a dangerous
thing because there's
a long trail of discussion.
And it was interesting that
the whole discussion was not
about computational
modeling and it was not
about physics, Schrodinger,
or Born-Oppenheimer.
It was entirely about
whether this guy was
going to be able to find
dates or not in his life.
And it was actually a
very engaging discussion,
and it came out--
it was like 50%
said definitely because of the
tattoo, and 50% said no way.
And so I don't know where that--
but anyway.
Now this is another
cartoon that just
shows that the
electrons are the flies,
and the protons, the
nucleus, are these cows.
And they move
really slow, bulls.
I didn't mean to dis.
These guys are
going really fast.
This guy's kind of slow,
and that's really the point.
Electrons are fast
and light, and so it's
a good approximation.
How much lighter are they than
the proton or the nucleus?
AUDIENCE: 1 over 2,000.
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN:
Yeah, it's a couple--
it's like 1,000, right?
So that's enough lighter that
you can say, you know what?
At any given time, it's
a good approximation
to say that this thing is
pretty stationary with respect
to these things buzzing around.
That's the Born-Oppenheimer
approximation in cow language--
OK, cow-fly language.
Actually, this is
more Google image art.
So this is the
approximation we make.
What you can see is that we just
get rid of those nuclear terms.
We treat them as if
they're not moving
and they don't really matter
because at any given time what
we care about is the electronic
structure with the atoms fixed.
That's what we're
talking about here.
And you can solve for it.
It's a really good
approximation in many cases.
There are some fields
where it matters,
where this approximation
actually can break down
like in superconductivity.
We're not going to go there.
For us and the things we
care about, that's sort of--
the positions of the
atoms are frozen,
and then we solve
for the electrons.
That's fine, and that's
a good approximation.
OK, so any questions
about Born-Oppenheimer,
the Born-Oppenheimer surface?
You'll hear people say that,
the Born-Oppenheimer surface,
and now you know what they mean.
They mean the energy surface
where the electrons are always
in sort of their ground
state with respect
to the nuclei positions because
they always have enough time
to get there because they move
so much faster than the nuclei.
That's the Born-Oppenheimer
[INAUDIBLE]..
You can pull that out
as well in conversation.
Now that's one approximation.
That kind of helps.
It really doesn't
help the key problem,
which is that
many-body-interaction thing.
So that's like the real--
that's the real issue here.
How do we get over this
electron-electron interaction?
And don't even let me say it,
electron-electron-electron
interaction because you can
have like three-body effects.
It's a many-body world,
but we can't do that.
We can't do that on a computer
in a good-enough time scale
to be applicable to
materials, so we simplify.
And you covered this, right?
This is not-- but
we're getting back
into our feeling
with this, right?
But you did cover this.
Am I correct?
OK, good.
One person got it.
But thank you for
that in the back.
Now, OK, there were basically
two paths because they saw this
and they knew, they
being the people thinking
about computational materials,
physics, and chemistry
back in the 1940s.
They knew they needed
to do something.
And so there were
essentially two paths.
There was a path that
most chemists took,
and there was a path
that most physicists
took starting in sort of
the '60s really, actually.
The path that the chemists
took is to say, you know what?
We're not going to mess
with the Hamiltonian.
We are not going
to mess with this.
This is right.
The physics of this is
correct, so we don't
want to play around with that.
Most of what the chemists
did was to play around
with the wave function.
So what they did is--
let me go back.
Sorry.
I think I had the
Schrodinger equation here.
H-- remember Schrodinger
equation, H psi equals E psi.
Well, they played with psi.
So instead of saying
that psi can be complex
as it needs to be with all the
freedom that it needs to have,
they said no, we're going to
start to restrict that freedom.
That's really how quantum
chemistry sort of began.
I mean, there was some
perturbation theory,
but a lot of the real
advances in quantum chemistry
in the beginning happened in
making approximations for this,
for the wave function.
They said keep H, mess with psi.
Make it simple.
And if you make it simple, it
becomes a tractable problem,
right?
How many of you have heard
of a determinant, a Slater
determinant?
Slater was here at MIT, and
it was a really important
contribution to
quantum chemistry
was to be able to write psi,
keep the important properties
that you need but to write
it in a much simpler--
in a very simplified way.
So you lose information.
It's not the same
psi that you need.
It's not the correct
psi, but it's
sort of an approximate
version of it.
That's kind of where
quantum chemistry--
that's what Hartree-Fock
theory is based on.
Then you have sort of the
physics world in the 1960s.
And I've shown you the
picture of Walter Kohn, who
is the only person to win a
Nobel Prize in computation,
so far at least.
And he won it for a
density function--
for his development of
density functional theory.
Now that is taking sort
of the opposite approach.
What that is doing that
is saying, OK, ignore psi.
Psi is just too hard.
Even if you simplify it,
it's a really hard thing
to write in a computer and to
represent accurately, and so
let's just forget about that
and work only with the density.
I take it you did talk
about this last week, right?
So in density functional theory,
that's where it gets its name.
You just get rid of psi
by not thinking about it
and by solving the problem of
the density instead of the wave
function.
So it's the density of the
electrons instead of the wave
function of the electrons.
Now when you do that,
effectively-- and again,
my goal here in this class is
not to go deep mathematics here
because I know many of you
haven't had quantum yet,
but I want you to come
away with an intuitive
picture for what's happening.
What happened in the 1960s when
these communities were really
developing computational quantum
mechanics for the first time?
And what this
does-- no, but stay.
It's still going to be good.
OK, go ahead.
We'll fill you in
when you come back.
What this does to
say that I want
to think about the density
instead of the wave function
is effectively it modifies H.
So now instead of modifying psi,
you actually are
changing H considerably--
considerably.
But you hope that
you don't change it
so much that it's wrong or
that it's unphysical, right?
And density functional
theory effectively
is a theory that simplifies
H, the Hamiltonian,
the expression for the energy.
You basically get rid of
those complex, many-particle
interactions from H and you put
effective potentials into it.
That's density
functional theory.
Now, both of them get rid
of this many-body problem.
Actually, see, what you do in
quantum chemistry is you change
the wave function so it's
a single-particle wave
function, which basically means
when you solve the equations,
there are no more
many-body terms left.
And in density
functional theory,
you change the Hamiltonian so
that you explicitly get rid
of the many-body interactions.
Either way, you're left with
a single-particle picture.
That's really the trick.
In both communities,
what you end up with
is a single-particle picture.
Now that's something that you
can solve in less than the age
of the universe on a
computer, and that's the key.
You're left with these
single-particle pictures.
What is this
single-particle picture?
Who can tell me?
Did you talk about that?
You go from a many-body picture
to a single-particle picture.
Take a guess.
Yeah, I see that
you want to guess.
Yeah, yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: It's one where all
the variables in your theory
only sort of depend on--
all the things in
your theory only
depend on the variables
for one particle.
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN:
Basically yes.
I mean, that's
exactly it, right?
So now my electrons--
my electrons are like this.
In my real system, here
are my electrons, all
those E's, and there they are.
But what I'm saying
is that this isn't--
I can't describe
this because, look,
that's when I have to take
into account these guys.
Look, that's this term
here, the R minus r
is the relative positions
of two electrons.
And I even need
to take these guys
and these guys and those guys,
and that's the many-body part.
That's not solvable, basically,
not for computational material
science.
So what we need to do is--
I mean, it's solvable in certain
ways, but it's very hard.
I should put it that way.
So the single-particle
picture is to say, sorry,
but you're going to lose all
this individualness here,
and each electron--
I'm going to now map
this guy over here--
is only going to feel
some potential field,
some mean field, some
mean potential average
of all of those other electrons.
It swims in an
average potential now.
And so I basically have
just eliminated the problem.
The problem was this.
It's too hard to solve on
the computer, certainly
analytically but
also on computer.
And so I've changed it to this.
That's basically what
both of these things do.
Quantum chemistry and
density functional theory
both result in this picture,
this very simplified picture.
It's called a mean-field
picture because each electron
is in a mean field
of the rest of them.
They do it in different ways.
Quantum chemists do it by
simplifying the wave function,
and the physicists
did it originally
by simplifying the Hamiltonian.
And there was a lot of
really interesting sort
of discussion, to
put it lightly,
about which path was better.
And then I think now
both communities,
I think, work in both ways.
There's a lot of back and forth.
But density functional
theory is definitely
the one we're going to
work on with this class
because it strikes a balance.
It strikes a very nice
balance as a method that
can capture enough accuracy.
It sacrifices something.
It definitely
sacrifices something.
You approximate the Hamiltonian.
But it doesn't sacrifice--
it still is pretty accurate,
and it's been shown
to be pretty accurate
for many, many, many problems.
And you can see that it's also
right in this region here,
which is a really
nice region to be in.
Now why is this a nice region
to be in on the vertical axis?
AUDIENCE: You can solve
for larger molecules.
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN: You can
solve for large molecules,
yeah.
What else?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It's growing pretty
quickly, so in the future
you'll be able to
do even more atoms.
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN: Totally.
Nice n-cubed scaling--
well, sorry, n-cubed scaling
with the method with size but
also increase in the speed
here.
What else?
What else might this
be a nice sweet spot
for computational
materials design?
1,000 to 10,000 atoms, sort of
where the limits of DFT are.
Well, what are we solving for?
Electrons, right?
We're solving for those
properties of electrons.
Now, why is this
a nice sweet spot?
Well, when might I need less
or more atoms than that?
OK, so let's say I'm in
coupled cluster, which
is one of these ways of making
the wave function simpler.
It's a very accurate method,
but you can only do today,
I don't know, 15 atoms
accurately, maybe 20.
What would be
limiting about that?
Is 20 atoms enough?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If you're
trying to figure out, say,
the electrical properties
of some material,
you don't really
have enough space
to take into account some
three-dimensional block
of stuff.
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN: And when
would you run out of space?
What matters?
AUDIENCE: Boundary conditions
and things like that.
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if you're
talking quantum dots or things
like that, you have
different sizes
contributing to the
properties of the material.
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN: Yeah,
and you can't really
explore those with
just 20 atoms.
Definitely a good point.
Anything else?
Why else might this--
so it's not just--
it's the size.
When I hear it's the size of
the material you want to study
and 1 to 10,000 is a
pretty good region,
you can play a
lot-- welcome back.
You can play a lot
with that size range.
You can model a lot of
materials in that size range.
But importantly, the
thing you're modeling
are the electrons.
And so what counts,
it's not just
about how many atoms you can
put into your simulation.
That's not what counts.
You see these titles of papers
like million-atom simulation,
billion-atom simulation,
trillion-atom simulation.
OK, that's cool.
You get a lot of atoms.
Good for you.
But what matters?
What matters is did you need
those atoms for the property
you care about?
Did you need them?
Now in some cases, maybe you do.
But for electrons, very
often they're spread.
What they want to do is
kind of more dominated
by a few nearest-neighbor
distances,
maybe 10-nearest-neighbor
distances in a crystal.
In some cases they're very
spread out, like in a metal,
and then we can use periodic
boundary conditions,
and we can still
capture all the physics.
But when you have interfaces
or roughness or molecules,
the electrons aren't going to--
even if you put a
million atoms in,
you won't see anything different
than if you put a thousand
atoms in.
And that has--
for many problems.
For many problems, not all, but
for many cool materials-design
problems, that's the case.
And that's why this is such
a nice sweet spot of a method
because it hits in this range
where the stuff we care about,
electrons, happen
to kind of play
in this phase space of distance.
That's where DFT is.
That's why it's so powerful.
Any questions?
And right, I'm not
going to review.
I just kind of
went through this.
The approximation is to
work with the density,
and you sort of throw everything
into a density formalism,
and you punt on the exchange--
on this interaction term that's
all about this V. So density
functional theory is about what
functional you use to capture
these many-body effects
in a single-particle way.
That's really what
it comes down to.
And this is all sort
of review, right?
I kind of went through this.
You will not be
tested on this math,
but I think you went through
it already last week.
Correct?
Some nods.
OK.
And so you get
basically an equation
where the potential
that I just showed you
can be written as this potential
plus this exchange correlation
functional, which is basically
a function only of this one
electron.
That's why it works so well.
It's not a function anymore
of all these other electrons.
I kind of want to make
sure we get the key points.
Now the way you solve
this in a computer, which
is what the nanoHUB does
for you when it works--
I had some interesting crashes
last night on the nanoHUB--
is basically you
have this equation.
So what density
functional theory does,
you see, this is
the beauty of it.
What does that look like to you?
I mean, that looks like
something that we did. ,
That's definitely
your Hamiltonian,
but this equation now--
remember the many-body,
multiparticle mess that
we just showed you?
Now we're back
from that to this.
What does that look like,
it's reminiscent of,
and for which material?
It sort of looks back like
hydrogen almost, right?
That's not as simple as hydrogen
because V is now more complex,
but it basically
turned the problem back
into a single-particle problem.
So now that's the
equation we solve
once we go through the
density functional theory
approximation.
And you have to
solve it in what's
called a self-consistent
way, which
is to say you have to start
with a guess for your density.
You plug it into the
equation, and you get out
these wave functions.
So you do get wave functions
in density function theory,
but they're essentially just
a basis for the density.
The conceptual framework is
to work with the density.
So you start with the density.
You plug it into here,
and you solve this.
The computer solves this, and
it gets you a wave function.
And then from that wave function
you can get a new density
because the density
is, after all, just
this sum over these
things squared.
We know that because we
talked about how that's what
density is, electron density.
So does everybody know
what I'm talking about?
Probability-- electron
density is where it is.
It's a probability distribution.
And so that you get from that.
You put it back in here.
You do it again, and
basically you stop when what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN:
When you're about right.
I love that answer.
Tell me more.
When do you stop?
If it's a self-consistent
loop, I guess for this.
I put it in here.
I get a new set of these.
They give me a new this, and
I put that back in there,
and I get a new set.
When should I stop?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN: Yeah,
when it doesn't change,
when the answer doesn't change.
And so that's what this
is showing you here.
Is it self-consistent means
it didn't change, basically.
You did this loop,
and it didn't change.
And that's what it'll
look like in the code.
You'll see energies,
total energies
coming out of the
system, and they'll
be sort of converging
to a value.
And then the code will
say, OK, it's close enough.
Now the other key thing is
you have to write these phis.
When you talk about a phi--
so this is the
Schrodinger equation.
And then you write the psi in
terms of some set of orbitals.
But to write an orbital--
I mean, if I want
to write anything--
if I want to write anything
on a computer-- that's
my electron density.
It's my orbital.
I need to represent it
mathematically somehow.
The computer can't
just take that.
So you need functions
to represent these,
and those are called
basis functions.
So those basis
functions-- and you
can use different kinds
of basis functions.
You can use Gaussians.
You can just use--
if I want Gaussians, I would put
a nice one there and then maybe
some more ones here.
Well, that wouldn't work.
Anyway, you need a bunch
of Gaussians centered
in different places,
and you add them up,
and they'd give you that
function back, approximately.
So we have to represent these
things with basis functions.
You can use plane waves, which
are really good for solids.
You can use plane waves
for atoms as well.
They're nice.
Plane waves are nice for solids
because they're periodic, which
is what your wave function is.
Gesundheit.
The double.
You can use them for atoms
and molecules as well,
but you have to be a little
careful because a plane
wave goes through the whole
cell of the simulation,
but your molecule only
takes up a small part of it.
So with plane waves,
you're actually
sort of wasting those functions.
But if you do it in a
smart way, it's not so bad.
All right, so that's sort of--
I wanted to kind
of touch on that.
This is a really cool
movie that Lynn found.
Why do we care?
Well, this is the
kind of thing you
can do when you know
where these electrons are
for complex systems.
This is a porphyrin ring.
I think it's got zinc in the
center from this group here.
And you can actually show--
this is a computation,
and you can actually
show what happens
to the electrons--
the density of electrons
when you shine lasers on it.
Now it turns out that
this is-- and there it is.
So now you're going
to push on the system
with lasers, which
cause a resonance,
and it causes these
electrons to start
sloshing back and forth
as you pump this porphyrin
ring with lasers.
So you can see the
lasers down here.
They're not actually real.
It's a computation.
But what you see
is very important.
Look at that slosh.
Look at that.
Now that is really important.
The sloshing of those electrons
is really, really important
for how this molecule
absorbs light,
and that's why it was studied
because this is what we're
going to end with today is where
those electrons are determines
the band gap of the
molecule, and it determines
its optical properties,
what we talked
about in the very beginning,
something we really
need when we're talking
about photoactive materials
like porphyrin.
And porphyrin has many
important properties, right?
It's a beautiful molecule.
These are the kinds
of molecules and these
are the kinds of
things you can get now
using these approximations.
You can get electron densities
and then correlate those
to something really important.
And that's what we're going
to do by the end of today
and in our homeworks
for solar thermal fuels.
Do you guys want me to post
these videos on Steller?
Do you guys look at
the Stellar stuff?
OK, I'll definitely
do that then.
I wasn't sure if anybody--
OK.
So any questions?
So that was sort of a little
review of where we are.
Let's do a calculation.
Actually, before we move
on, let's just do a calc--
now that's a little
embarrassing.
Let's put that over here.
That was taken a few years ago.
Now there's MIT.
Oh yeah.
It was out in Berkeley, yeah.
Now let's see if this works.
Aha!
Now the two tools that
matter for quantum mechanics
in this toolset are quantum
chemistry-- and this
is doing just what I said.
It's doing what those
quantum chemists like to do.
It's messing with
the wave function.
And this is the density
functional theory code
we're going to use SIESTA,
which is a cool name.
And this is actually
messing with the density.
This is density
functional theory.
Although this now, like I
said, the two communities
have overlapped.
This code now can also do
density functional theory.
But these are the two
quantum-mechanics codes
we're going to use.
And if you go-- let's
say you go to here.
I just want to just do one
little calculation together.
And what I want to
do is the following.
There's some inputs
here that are
worth-- oh, you're kidding me.
I can't scroll.
Unbelievable.
Well, that's really frustrating.
So there's no way-- it
doesn't let me actually
scroll down here.
Oh, there.
Thank you.
OK, I'm good.
So here you see it's got water,
and there are some things
you can do-- that's right.
So the cursor has to
actually be over there.
And here are some inputs.
So we'll work with water.
That's the basis set.
Low means like what?
Do you think that's good or bad?
Yeah, it's not very good.
Medium and high, those
are the three options.
Now G means Gaussians.
The other person who won the
Nobel Prize together with Kohn
that year was Pople,
and Pople won it
for some really
important work that he
did relating to these
basis sets, basically,
and some important
chemistry work he'd done.
But that G stands for
Gaussian, and the 3-21G
is a set that he
made which became
incredibly important to helping
quantum chemistry move forward.
He made sets of basis sets.
And if you google
"basis set order form,"
there's a website where
you can enter any element,
and there are hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of basis
sets that have been
developed and published,
and these are some of them.
And this is just--
you go from here
to the next and the next one.
You just add more
functions, basically,
and so the calculation
gets longer.
When is it enough?
When do I have enough
of a basis set?
That was one question
I wanted to discuss.
10?
Oh, I love that answer.
I thought 10 was
pretty good too.
It depends.
That's the answer.
Now what does it depend on?
AUDIENCE: What kind of
calculation you're doing.
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN: And?
AUDIENCE: How accurate you
want the results to be.
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN: How accurate
you want your results to be,
what calculation you're doing.
What do you mean by what
calculation you're doing?
AUDIENCE: If you
just want energy
or whether you want to get
properties [INAUDIBLE]..
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN:
OK, so the property.
It depends on the property
you're calculating.
How do you know when to stop?
So I'm going to do a
calculation with 3-21G,
and I'm going to calculate
the water molecule using
the formalism you just saw.
That's what this code is doing.
And you're going to see a
nice pretty picture of water.
There it is.
And then you have
these key outputs.
And there's my total energy.
My total energy of
this water molecule
is 2,056.56 electronvolts.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What's a basis set?
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN: Yeah.
So a basis set is
those functions
that the computer needs to
represent the wave functions.
So if this is your
wave function--
if your wave function
looks like this--
let's say this is phi versus r.
By the way, does anybody know
which wave function this is?
That is a wave function.
I didn't just make it up.
It belongs to an element.
It's the 1s orbital of
hydrogen. You got it.
That's the r dependence of
the 1s orbital of hydrogen.
It looks like an exponential.
So should I use an
exponential to represent
this in a computer?
You bet except
no, and the reason
is that those are
slow to calculate.
Exponentials are kind of
slow, exponential functions.
So early on
exponentials were used,
and then it was realized
that you could actually
represent this pretty darn
well with Gaussians, like three
or four Gaussians, and
you'd kind of get it right.
You'd never get this part here.
You can't get a finite slope
at zero with Gaussians,
but you can come so close
that it doesn't matter.
And so because Gaussians
have advantages--
we won't go into
details, but I'm
happy to talk to
anybody who wants.
Gaussians have
advantages in terms
of computing
integrals on computers
so that you can actually use
some of the formalism that's
been developed to do
integration with Gaussians
and do it very quickly
and efficiently.
You cannot do it
with exponentials.
And because of that,
the chemists early on
started using Gaussians
for their basic sets,
and all these Pople sets,
those are all Gaussians.
Now when you use
plane waves, that's
a different kind of function.
That's a sine and
cosine function.
And so there you're
using functions like this
to reproduce your psi.
Either way, what
you're doing is you're
going to add a
bunch of functions
together to try to
make up your psi,
and you've got to have
enough to do it justice.
And that was the
question is how do you
know when you've had enough?
It's a very important part and
problem in quantum mechanics--
in computing with
quantum mechanics
that doesn't exist in
classical potentials, right?
See, classical potentials, this
is not a convergence problem.
You don't converge
your basis set.
You just have a potential,
and you calculate it.
Here you have to represent
psi mathematically somehow.
Here you're doing
it with Gaussians.
With SIESTA, actually
it's not plane waves.
It's a different kind of
function like Gaussians.
But in a way, it doesn't matter.
They should all converge
to the same answer, right?
You just have to
understand that this is
what's going on under the hood.
So again I ask,
when is it enough?
When do I have enough
basis functions?
AUDIENCE: When you approximate
your wave function well enough
with your basis set.
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN: And how
do I know if I've done that?
AUDIENCE: When you check
for self-consistency.
Is that [INAUDIBLE]?
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN: That's
within a single calculation.
How do I know I've used
a good-enough basis set?
Well, let's go back.
Let's go back a second
to what Sam said.
It depends on the property.
So now I'm going to
tell you a property.
I want to know the binding
energy of a water molecule.
How can I calculate that?
Somebody tell me how
I calculate that.
I have the energy of
the water molecule.
Is that the binding energy?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The atoms that
are really far away,
and then you
calculate the energy.
And then if they
have energy with them
close together minus the far
away, that will [INAUDIBLE]..
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN: Exactly.
So the energy-- so the
binding energy, E bind,
is equal to the energy of the
molecule minus the energy sum
over the energy of the atoms.
So that's the property
I want to calculate.
It could have been
another property.
Could have been-- let's
say this is the gap.
Yeah, it could have been the
electronic gap of the material.
Now how do I know if I've
used enough basis functions?
This is really important.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Experimental data.
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN: OK, good.
See if it matches
experimental data.
Except there may
be other reasons
it doesn't match experimental
data, not just the basis set.
So how do I know if I've
just converged the basis set?
AUDIENCE: Get the
lattice parameters of it.
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN:
OK or along those
lines, but that's still
comparing with experiment,
which is always a good
thing to do when you can.
Well, what if I just
do this calculation
and then I do another one
with a higher basis set
and it doesn't change?
How about that?
Well, it's the same as
the self-consistent thing.
Once the answer doesn't
change, I've converged.
But this isn't part of a
single calculation now.
This is part of more
than one calculation
that you have to do.
So I'm going to go to a
larger basis set like medium
and do simulate.
And then it's going
to calculate this,
and let's see what happened.
The gap-- OK, there it is again.
Thank you.
The gap went to 19.
Oh boy.
So now my key output--
let's see, is
2,068.6 electrons--
electronvolts-- is the
energy with this basis set.
Everything else is the same.
And with the first basis set,
it's 2,056 electronvolts.
Am I converged?
Trick question.
You still don't know.
Well, except there's
something else to it
that I'm trying to
get out of you guys.
It's not an easy-- it's
not an easy thing to see,
but it's really
important because we're
talking about something
called convergence
that you don't really have in
your classical force fields.
You just have a
classical force field,
and then you have another
one or another one, right?
But here we're converging
within one calculation,
one level of theory.
And so what counts--
you have to do this
when you do simulations.
But what counts here is
not the total energy.
Why?
Because that's not the thing
I'm trying to converge.
I'm trying to
converge this I said,
the binding energy, which
is a difference of energies.
And it very well may be that
the binding energy converges
with a really bad
basis set right away
and doesn't change when I get my
next basis set or my next one.
Even though the total
energies are changing,
they're changing in such a
way that the error cancels
completely.
This is the thing.
It depends-- that's
why I love it depends.
It depends is such
a great answer--
on the property
you're simulating,
and you have to do convergence
for the property you
care about.
It could have been the gap.
20.7 was the low basis, and
the higher basis is 19.7.
That's a whole EV difference
in the electronic gap.
That's a lot of difference.
That doesn't sound very good.
Maybe we should go to-- let's
say we care about the gap.
Let's go to one higher.
Use a higher basis set.
And we see here now the
gap, oh, it changed again.
Uh oh.
And so now it went to 18.
So we had, with the
highest basis set,
18, with the medium one, 19,
and with the lowest one, 20.
So you can see it's
actually going down,
which means the right
answer is probably
going to be even lower.
Does that look converged?
Not to me.
You actually need a
higher basis set still.
This tool won't allow it because
it's not a very flexible tool,
but that's OK.
That's not the point.
So does everybody
understand what
I'm talking about when
I say convergence?
We will come back
to convergence again
when we do solids because
there's another thing in solids
you have to converge, not just
your basis set but something
else, which we'll
come back to and I'm
going to save it as a surprise,
very exciting surprise.
So we know that it can calculate
the binding energy of water.
There's one more question I
want to ask you about, this spin
thing here.
Default-- default means
that it took a guess.
And you can see that the
guess it made for water
is that it's a spin singlet.
Now we talked about
this in lecture two.
Does everybody know what
a spin singlet means?
So we're talking about
electrons filling orbitals.
Remember, we're solving
for those electrons,
and they fill
orbitals like this.
Remember Pauli exclusion
and all that and filling--
OK?
Now if I-- this is the last
question I want to ask.
Then we'll go back
to the lecture.
Oxygen is 1s.
Somebody tell me what else is
in oxygen. How many electrons?
Three?
Eight.
So 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Right?
Good.
Very good.
Now, is that a spin singlet?
Does everybody remember what
singlet, doublet, triplet--
so singlet, triplet,
doublet is very important
because it tells the computer
how these electrons are
filling these orbitals.
So that's another
really important part
of these simulations.
A singlet means that
overall you have
the same number of
spins pointing up
as spins pointing down.
Is that what I have for oxygen?
Uh uh.
So a doublet is when I have
one more pointing up or down,
and a triplet is when I have
two extra electrons pointing
up or down.
Doesn't matter.
So this is actually-- the
oxygen atom is a triplet.
Now what about water?
Well, it turns out
water is a singlet.
So the default
guessed it correctly.
Let's do the oxygen atom.
Well, the code will do
whatever spin state you say.
I'm going to say now that I just
want oxygen. So there it is.
I'm going to do it
with the same basis.
And now here it
is, and oh, that's
a beautiful picture of oxygen.
And now you go to key outputs,
and there's the energy.
OK, so I'm going to do my
calculation of this binding
energy.
I just calculated the
energy of the atom.
Can I use that?
What's wrong with that?
Look at the top line.
No, second from the top line.
What did it do?
It did a singlet.
Uh oh.
It did this.
It defaulted incorrectly.
Never trust tools.
Always know what you're doing.
That's my point.
And these are the key
things you need to know.
You need to know that
the basis, and you've
got to know about spin.
You've got to know how those
electrons filled their levels.
And what this calculation
did is it did this.
Did it get an answer?
Sure.
Is it oxygen?
Well, yes.
in some very strange,
excited state of oxygen. But
that's not the right
state of oxygen.
And, in fact, you can
tell because remember
this energy, 2,032.1?
And now let's give it
the right spin state.
Let's make it a triplet,
which we know oxygen is,
and let's see what
the energy is.
OK, go away.
I know you're there.
Yes, that's the oxygen atom.
And now when I use the right
spin state, it's 2,035.6.
Do you see how much
lower the energy went?
Because, see, the right oxygen
is the way oxygen wants to be.
It's the ground
state of that atom.
If I compare it with
this excited state,
it's three electronvolts
higher in energy.
The more negative,
the more stable,
the more energy that has, the
more happy those electrons are.
So that means that the
electrons and oxygen really
want to be in a triplet
state, and you better
use that energy to do
things like calculate
the binding energy.
So you've got to think
about the spin state.
So that was the
other thing I wanted
to mention in doing this,
spin state and basis sets.
Any questions?
No questions?
In the last half hour or
so, I want to get to--
oh, 35 minutes even--
I want to get to this
first application
that I'm really excited about.
And I think you're kind
of now in a place where
we can actually think
about these-- think
about applications
for molecules.
And that's an area--
I want to introduce solar
chemical fuels to you,
and then we're going to talk
about why this kind of modeling
is so important here
and what we can do.
And then you'll have a
homework related to this.
OK, I love this.
I love that materials
are going to determine--
and then here we are down here.
I love this too.
I think I've shown
this to you, right,
but it never hurts
to show this again
because it's a cool picture,
and this is where we live.
We're past silicon, man.
That's old.
Never better against silicon.
Never.
It's still a really
important material.
But on the left, plastics.
Oh, what's that?
That is, I think, a
nanotube or a-- it's
either a nanotube or some
other sort of 2D material
wrapped up into like a gear that
I think has never been made.
Maybe it's not a good
picture, but it looked good,
and I grabbed it in five
seconds from Google.
Anyway, I'm going to skip this.
I'll talk about this later.
Solar, we get a
lot of it, right?
You guys have seen this.
How many of you have seen this?
There's a whole lot of solar.
So this is a cool comparison.
Look.
It beats coal.
I mean, forget
about like we know
the resource of
solar beats things
like tidal and tides,
waves, geothermal, hydro,
all the other
renewables combined.
But it beats coal.
That's pretty cool.
Well, biomass would be if
you take all the arable land.
You've got to remember,
these numbers-- and this
is the author of this
fairly recent study.
But those numbers have many
assumptions go into them,
and so there's a lot
of debate about what
the right numbers are.
To within a factor
of 2 to 10, these
are probably the right numbers.
But biomass, if you
take the arable land
where you're not going to
cause a huge famine in the area
and you kind of add
that up, you try
to consider water
resources and other things.
You can actually
compute using, say,
some crop or set of crops--
sugarcane, maybe other things,
switchgrass-- how much energy
could you generate in a year?
And that's about it.
I think-- and I don't remember.
There was a number with
biomass that was 11
that I saw for a
while in the study,
but that was if you literally
stop growing food for people
and you just take all land that
can be used to grow anything
and you make fuel, and you're
still at considerably less
than other resources.
I'm not saying biofuels isn't
a really important direction.
But I kind of like
these comparisons.
There we are.
We use not much compared to
how much we have in the sun.
These are the different
ways you can use the sun.
And I want to talk
about this one now.
So I think you know about this.
You take the sun, and
you make a lot of heat.
I'm going to actually
start with this
because it's related to this.
Here we take sun and
we make electrons.
That's going to be our next
homework-assignment example
that we'll talk about when we
do solids because from the band
structure of a solid--
and the band structure
is nothing more than
this for solids.
From the band
structure of a solid,
I can explain to you-- you
can explain to your friends
why silicon is so expensive--
why silicon is too expensive.
And then you can also
take the sun's energy
and just try to make
fuels directly out of it.
So what are solar thermal fuels?
Well, like I said, I
want to start with heat
because heat is--
and this will be a fairly
quick introduction.
But heat is something--
it's one of the oldest
technologies we know about in
terms of how to use the sun.
Paint the barrel black.
Put it on the roof.
Put water in it.
It gets hot.
It's a really simple technology.
It works really well, and
it's used all over the world.
You can also, if you want
higher temperatures because you
want to make electricity, you
can go to large-scale plants
because there you need
large scale because you
need to focus the sun's energy
to get much higher temperatures
like, say, 500 Celsius to
drive some sort of cycle
like a Stirling
engine or something.
If you do that, you
can make electricity.
Those are concentrated
solar power plants.
Here's the distribution.
That is actually
interesting, right?
This is how much-- there's
sort of capacity and produced.
But you can see that using
solar thermal as heat
is actually the
second-most-utilized renewable
resource in the world.
But that's the
painting the barrel
black and putting
it on your rooftop.
That's not making electricity.
So in the world this is actually
a very heavily used alternative
energy.
That is almost completely
unused in this country.
I think in terms of countries
that use the sun in this way,
we're like number 17.
There are some places that are
trying to make power with it
but very few.
It's a hard thing to do.
I think 15 of the 20 existing
CSP plants are in Spain.
The Spanish love this.
But you can just sort
of see where it stands.
Anyway, the point is there are
challenges with using the sun's
energy in the form of heat.
One of them is that you lose
the energy, reradiation.
As soon as you absorb heat,
it starts going out way,
so you've got to contain it.
And it's still going to leak.
So in some of these
plants, you actually
pump in
fossil-fuel-based energy.
So you use the sun to
concentrate on, say,
a molten salt in a tower, so
a phase change of material.
You get it up to really high
energy over the phase change.
You all took 3012.
Know many of you
did, so you know
about when I say
phase change, you're
going up this heat,
this latent heat,
and you're storing a
bunch of energy that way.
And then you want
to keep it up there.
So you actually pump
in fossil-fuel energy
because it's reradiating
heat out and losing energy,
and you don't want
it to slip back down.
That's not a good thing.
And really importantly is
this is not transportable.
So you can't use heat from the
sun except where you make it.
So that's where solar
chemical comes in.
Oh, there's that--
we're number--
well, we're after Macedonia.
Anyway, Albania.
We don't use solar
thermal this way,
and I don't understand why.
It's a very inexpensive
renewable resource.
Solar chemical-- so in
solar chemical, what you do
is you take a molecule-- in
this case, it's azobenzene.
And you shine a light on it, and
it goes into a different state.
Now the important thing is
that-- so that's the charging.
Charge it by the sun.
In this different state,
it's storing energy,
and that can be released.
It can be released
in the form of heat.
So you've got a
way of closed-cycle
capturing and storing
the sun's energy,
triggering this state
to release that energy
in the form of heat.
It's transportable.
It can be stored for
as long as you want.
It's renewable.
It's cheap, and
it's a closed cycle.
That's the dream.
Now this was very heavily
studied 30, 40 years ago.
And the reason as a
field it was abandoned
is because for
all the cases that
were studied in the 1970s
that do this closed loop,
they degrade.
So you get this cycle.
You charge up your
fuel from the sun.
You use it as heat somewhere.
You bring it back.
You charge it again.
You use it again.
And after 10 cycles, half
of your fuel is toluene.
That's a problem.
Some thoughts on that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN: Yeah.
That was a good one.
It was actually well timed.
And I like that
kind of feedback.
The papers of the times
were saying things
like an energy-storage plant,
although technically feasible,
is not economically
justified because there's
an upfront cost for this fuel.
And if it doesn't cycle, if
it just degrades in 10 cycles,
you can't justify the cost.
So there's a lot
of work on this,
and those are the
degradation products.
I won't go into it, but
I'll leave it in your notes.
A lot of work was done.
Many papers were written,
and a lot of experiments
were done to fix this problem,
but no magic bullet was found.
So they would substitute
things into molecules.
They'd put metal atoms
into the molecules.
They'd do what are called
push-pull substitutions.
And no matter what they
did to these things,
if they made them
more cyclical, like 10
to the third cycles,
which isn't bad,
then they'd be terrible
in their energy density.
If they made them really
high energy density,
then maybe they were really
bad at absorbing sunlight.
So no matter what they did,
they couldn't fix this problem.
And this is where it's
just such a great time
to tackle it again.
The reason is that
if you wanted to do
100,000 calculations of
solids when this material was
being studied heavily--
if you wanted to screen
100,000 materials,
it would take you 30
years in 1980 to do that,
and today it takes a few days.
Not on the nanoHUB necessarily--
maybe they're back to 30 years.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN:
Depends where you compute.
But we're just a
whole generation
later in what we can tackle
with computational quantum
mechanics.
Now I'm going to
end by telling you
why you need quantum mechanics.
So this is a really cool
time to work on this problem,
and this wasn't
available back then when
it was such a big deal.
And then, of course,
there's the sort
of advances we've made on
the synthesis side, which
I won't talk about because
this is a class on computation.
So what we've done--
and this is research
that we're doing--
is we've shown that there
are new ways-- we've
shown computationally
that there are new ways
to tackle the problem.
We've shown that you
can take a molecule that
does this switch--
there are many
molecules that do this.
How many of you have
heard of photo switches?
What have you heard of
them being used for?
Have you heard of them
being used for anything?
Well, they have been studied
a lot but in what fields?
You have a molecule
that you shine light on,
and it goes like this.
And then you shine
a different light
on it or you just take the light
off maybe, and it goes back--
photo switches.
Where might that be useful?
AUDIENCE: It kind of reminds
me of like LCD screens
but it's a bit different.
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN: Yeah.
Well, actually
mechanical computing
is a big deal or
nanomechanical memory,
optomechanical functions.
There are actually
many areas where
these sorts of
switching molecules
like stilbene and
azobenzene and stuff
that the name is so long
I can't write it here--
spiropyran-- these
are very heavily
studied, these optically
activated switching, big deal.
But they're all terrible
solar thermal fuels.
They're terrible.
They don't store much
energy, and they go back
in a few minutes.
So what we've realized is that
you can actually turn them
into good ones, and the
way you do that is you
put them on a template.
So you take a molecule
that's one of these switches.
There are many switches.
You stick it on a
template, and what
happens is when you
stick it on a template
you have new chemistry
that you can do,
and that's really the key.
Now we're going to come back
to you in a few minutes is
this picture, so I wanted
to just tell you what it is.
This is what the molecule does.
This is a reaction pathway.
This is the energy
curve for the molecule.
So it's down here.
You shine light on it, and
it goes up over this barrier,
and it drops you down
here into a new state.
In this case, it's azobenzene.
It's going from trans to cis.
How many of you have heard
of trans/cis, trans and cis
isomers?
So you know about
photo switches then.
Not all trans/cis states are
photo accessible, but many are.
That's all this is doing.
And then when you want
to release the heat,
you trigger it.
And it goes over this barrier,
like say with a catalyst,
and it releases
this much energy.
So that's your storage energy.
That's how much energy
that molecule stored.
And this back-reaction barrier's
related to the lifetime
of the stored state.
We're going to
come back to this.
So these are-- what we
did is some work that
showed that you can put
these onto nanotubes
and you can make them
into good switches,
and I'm not going to
go into the details.
But basically you see
this is the advantage
of computational
quantum mechanics
today is that we
can do chemistry
in the computer on these
switches and screen
hundreds of ideas in a week.
And we can calculate the things
like how much energy they store
or how stable they
are in a matter
of an hour on a computer.
So this is the
perfect time to try
to tackle old problems like
this that weren't solved
a generation ago
but that you can
play with them with many
different directions
computationally.
And this is just an example.
And don't worry
about the details,
but this was that photo switch.
This is how much energy is
stored on its own, this line up
here.
And now we can tweak it by
putting it on this template
and doing different chemistries.
We can make it store three
times as much energy.
So we can triple the storage
energy of these molecules
just by playing with the
chemistry when you put them
on a rigid template.
That's the idea.
At the same time, we can
tune the barrier back,
and we can have
cases like this one
where you triple
the storage density
and you increase the
barrier to going back.
And that's really
important because you
want to be able to tune
those things separately
because the back barrier is
related to how long it stays
in the charged state.
So that's the key, and so
we've developed materials
like this that are very
competitive with the best
lithium-ion batteries in terms
of their energy densities.
Any questions about these?
I'm kind of going
through this quickly,
but I don't want to
get bogged down by too
much of the details.
So there are many
template materials
that you can put these on.
You have to use
a template or you
can't get this new chemistry.
And there are many
switches that let you
go back and forth like this.
And what we've
shown is that this
is sort of a large phase space.
And so they're sort of
a new chemistry platform
out here for making
these kinds of fuels.
When I went to the Sloan
class, Energy Ventures,
and talked about
this, my thought was--
this is last fall--
I have this really
cool material.
It's going to save the world.
We're going to
replace coal plants.
We're going to make
electricity this way.
Everything's going to
be heated this way.
And they did a study
on commercialization,
and they came back and
they said, no, you're
not going to do any of that.
What you're going to do is
you're going to deice windows.
And at first I was
actually not happy
because I wanted to solve
the world's energy problems.
They looked at all these
different applications.
There's lots of
ways to use heat.
If you can store
the sun's energy
and release it as heat on
demand, that's a big deal--
and do it over and over again.
There are many
places you can use.
But they said, no, this
is going to be the best.
So actually we started
looking at that.
Actually Sam started
looking at that,
and he built a whole
test apparatus.
And Sam, with our solar
fields when they're made,
he'll be able to deice a window
for you in about five seconds,
and that's pretty cool.
So you can embed this
stuff inside of glass
and have it passively absorb
the sun's energy during the day.
In the morning, trigger
it, and it gives you
300 Celsius inside the glass.
You don't need to melt much
ice to get it to fall off.
So a lot of people--
and they talked
with MBTA and others
who would pay a
whole lot of money
to get something like that
because there's a lot of money
wasted on deicing.
It actually turns out
to be very interesting.
We also built a solar
cooker in collaboration
with the Slocum group,
and that basically
lets you cook with
the sun's energy
when the sun's not out because,
again, you have this ability
to take the sun's
energy and release it
as heat when you want it and
then recharge it the next day.
So we're really
excited about this.
Oh, and there's
our solar cooker.
I love this.
I'm going to take the last
15 minutes to talk about what
we can do with what we can do.
But this is the last thing I'll
tell you about the solar fuels.
I love this picture.
So these kinds of
things are not good.
This is a big deal.
This causes more deaths in
the third world than malaria
and AIDS combined,
wood-fired stoves.
Women primarily and sometimes
children spend 20 hours a week
searching for wood.
20 hours a week
of their time goes
to getting wood for burning.
This is the alternative if you
want to use the sun to cooking.
And I love these because this
is a restaurant in India,
and you can see these come with
specialized goggles and gloves.
And you can see why because
he's inside the oven.
He's getting burned
when he's cooking
because you can
focus on a point,
but you're not
going to be perfect.
So there's a lot
of sun hitting him.
It's not a very
comfortable way to cook.
But also you can only
cook when the sun's out.
So solar cookers, I think, could
play a really big role if you
can get them low cost--
these are over $600--
and if you can get
them to be able to cook
when it's more convenient.
OK, so I won't go
into those details.
This is the kind of
thing we do in my group,
and I get so excited about it.
We design things in a computer.
We make them, and
we build prototypes,
and it's sort of
a full loop here
to try to impact
interesting energy problems.
Now this leaves me
on the last part,
which is what I want to
talk about in the last 10
minutes of class.
Which is, OK, that's a
really cool energy problem.
You have to agree with that.
OK, you don't have
to agree with that,
but I think it's really
cool energy problem.
Where does computational
quantum mechanics fit into this?
OK, so this is what it does.
The fuel goes from here to here.
This is the reaction coordinate.
It goes from a low-energy
state to a high-energy state
when you shine the light on it.
Could I calculate-- now this
is how much energy it's stored,
which is related to the
density of the fuel, the energy
density of the fuel.
Remember, that's something
we had to kind of hike up
by a factor of three or four.
It's not really that good.
Could I have done that
with classical potentials?
Can I calculate this with
classical potentials?
What is this?
How do I calculate this?
Here's my solar fuel, and
this is the trans state,
and this is the cis state.
What is this difference?
How would I calculate
this energy difference?
How would you do that
calculation in a computer?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN: No, no,
no, this is calculationally.
Is that a word?
Yeah.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So they're
both sort of local minima
of the potentials.
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you
could theoretically
run some DFT simulation on
your trans configuration
and run a DFT simulation
on your cis configuration
and then get out the sort
of ground-state energies
for the two and compare them.
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN:
E cis minus E trans.
You bet.
That's it.
That's all this is--
equals delta H.
Now tell me why you said DFT.
Can't I use reacts or a
Lennard-Jones potential
to calculate that?
Why not?
AUDIENCE: The trans and cis may
have different types of bonds,
so [INAUDIBLE] electrons.
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN:
What if I had
a super-duper good potential?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] for
electrons [INAUDIBLE]..
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN:
But why do I need--
but hang on.
I mean, that would be true
with all the first part
of your class, right?
Everything you did in
the first part of class,
like straining wires and stuff,
captured energy of bonds.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You need to be given
the potential to use in order
to do a classical simulation.
So doing the quantum
simulation, you
just need to give the
configuration of atoms,
and then it--
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN:
Which is nice.
AUDIENCE: --find
the energy for you.
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN: Which
is certainly very nice,
but let's say I tell you
that I'm giving you a really
super-duper, really,
really, really,
honestly really good potential.
And that's what it's
called in the literature.
I put the word honest in it.
Could I calculate this
with classical potentials?
It's a difference of energies
between two molecules.
Can I calculate that with
a classical force field?
I'm seeing some of this and
I'm seeing some of this.
Well, actually yes.
You could calculate
the energy difference
between two molecules using
classical force fields.
What you have identified
is the challenge
of doing that, which
is that it's only going
to be as good as the potential.
Can the potential accurately
represent these two?
Well, you compare
with experiment.
You compare with higher-level
theories and you'll know.
But what if it can?
What if it can't?
Well, then this is
perfectly reasonable
to do with classical
force fields.
I don't need electrons
to calculate this.
I just need the right energies,
which is what classical force
fields are trying to capture.
Now, there's a key here though.
By the way, you could even
get this using a good--
if the classical force
fields were good enough,
you could get the back-reaction
barrier, the activation energy.
I want to make sure that
we understand context here.
When you do a
simulation, when you
do your computational
materials research,
it's not a one size
fits all kind of thing,
and it's not even a one problem,
one method kind of thing.
You can have one problem
with different properties
that require different methods.
And which is the
right method to use?
Well, very often
the answer to that
is whichever one is accurate
enough for the problem at hand
and fastest, and
so that's where you
have to know-- you have to
test and know where you sit
in accuracy phase space
with a given method,
and then you go ahead with it.
And if you can find a
classical potential that
seems to represent this
class of materials well
and you can validate that it's
getting this, by all means
use that because it's going to
be a whole lot faster than DFT.
However-- I should do that more
because it kind of felt good.
It actually kind of loosened my
shoulder, made me look silly.
There are things here I can't
do as classical potentials, not
even if I really, really
close my eyes and dreamt it.
They wouldn't happen.
What would that be?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN: Yeah.
So you're saying
there's a hint here.
This is what I'm
shining on the molecule.
Who's seen this before?
Yeah, you're feeling it.
This is the sun.
This is how much energy
comes to us from the sun.
And you can see that it's
dependent on the wavelength
of the light.
That's pretty cool, right?
And you know what's really
cool are these big, huge gaps.
See, this is if you go outside
of the earth's atmosphere,
you get this yellow line.
But on the planet, we
get this red curve.
We get all those
parts blocked out.
You just don't get
that frequency of light
on the earth.
And the reason is because
you have these molecules
in the atmosphere that are
blocking that part of the sun's
spectrum.
Isn't that pretty cool?
But this red is what
we get on the planet.
And the question is
how do these molecules
do in capturing that energy?
This is how we're
going to charge them.
This is how we're going
to charge them up.
Now that is related to
something else that's not here.
What might that be related to?
The band gap, exactly.
Exactly.
That is related.
So this all comes back to
where those electrons are.
So remember, we filled
these electrons up.
I'm just making them--
just for simplicity,
I'm not labeling
them s, p because
I'm not talking
about a particular thing here.
And then we filled them all up.
There were 10 electrons,
and we filled the levels
with those electrons,
and that was it.
But there's another
level up here,
and there's many
more levels up there
that don't have electrons.
And this distance here in energy
between the highest occupied
and lowest unoccupied
level, the HOMO/LUMOS,
that's called the band gap.
This is called the Highest
Occupied Molecular Orbital,
and this is the Lowest
Unoccupied Molecular Orbital.
And the difference
between them is the gap,
and that is so important
for optical properties
and electronic properties--
transport of electrons,
absorption of sun.
In this case, we care about the
absorption of the sun much more
than transport of electrons.
Now the reason
that's so important
is you see it goes back
to the hydrogen atom.
Somebody tell me
a weirdness thing
about looking out into space.
What do you see when you look
at the colors of hydrogen?
They're discrete.
Why?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN:
Yeah because,
remember, here's your electron.
It can only be in
these quantized levels.
It can only be in 1s or 2s,
and it cannot be in between.
Remember that?
How does that relate to
the absorption of sun
by a solar fuel?
Well, it's the same idea.
You see, when you
absorb sunlight--
see this H new?
Sunlight came into
this trans state,
and it made it go up onto
another energy surface.
That got it to twist.
Now when it absorbed the
sunlight, what really happened
is that the sun's energy
came into the molecule
and it kicked an electron
out of some happy place.
It's just hanging out with its
buddies, and a photon comes in,
and that photon kicks it up
here, and that's what does it.
That's what makes the
molecule change its shape,
that electron getting kicked up
into one of these other states.
Now the key here--
and this is what's related
to the hydrogen atom--
is that you see you
can't-- if you just shine--
so let me try to draw this
a little bit more clearly.
These are occupied levels, and
these are unoccupied levels,
and this is the gap.
So these would be
occupied, unoccupied.
You cannot shine light.
If I only have enough
energy from the photon
to take an electron
from here to here,
well, you're in no man's land.
You're just like that
electron in the hydrogen atom
trying to go in between
a 1s and a 2s orbital.
You can't do it.
There is no state here.
There's no wave function there
for the electron to be it.
And so there is a gap.
That is the minimum
energy it takes, right?
So how is that now
related to this?
Gap is related to
absorption how?
So this is actually wavelength.
So the energy gap goes
as 1 over this, right?
AUDIENCE: So for a molecule
only has a certain range
over which it can absorb light?
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN: Exactly.
Actually, for now we're just
saying it has a minimum energy
below which it cannot
absorb any light.
No photon below this
energy can do anything
in terms of exciting
these electrons up.
So the photons have
to be above that,
which means they have
to be-- if they have
to be above a certain
energy, then they have to be
below a certain wavelength.
So there's some--
does everybody see
there's some lambda
max where they're not
going to absorb any more?
So beyond some point here, they
can't take any of that sun.
That's it.
Does everybody see that?
They cannot absorb that sun.
Now would it be good-- if
lambda max were up here,
would that be OK?
Seems like it, but
there's a real problem
with that, which I'll come
back to probably next Tuesday.
But what would happen
if lambda max were here?
AUDIENCE: You're
missing out on a lot.
JEFFREY C GROSSMAN:
You're missing so much
of the sun's energy.
You just can't-- because
of quantum mechanics,
that darn quantum mechanics and
that electronic thing that you
cannot get from
classical potentials,
that electronic gap, you cannot
absorb light beyond the gap.
Which means if your
gap is here in energy,
all of this part of the
sunlight is completely wasted.
So I'm going to spend a
little time on this on Tuesday
because there's some really
cool questions about these photo
switches that we're going to
use quantum mechanics to model
in the homework.
And so I want to spend a little
more time on this Tuesday,
and then I'll talk a little
bit about hydrogen storage.
So we're going to pick up
with this picture on Tuesday.